sounds like all the other college offers
what a nice house kids going to college
for free what was I thinking look
players are hand-picked self-motivated
smart eyes fixed on their bright futures
they don't need what I do Beth they
don't need a coach who knows the game
inside and out I'm not a makeup artist
I'm a waitress when do I face reality
and just can't give up on a dream look
at all this work you've done that's the
last thing you want to do well you're
gonna regret it for the rest of your
life yeah I guess so do you like me I am
time you know what I liked I liked
having to show you were how you actually
wanted to dance yeah with us riff raff
afterwards those cool yeah you won't
fail fan out in 30 drop it uh hey I da
city holla drop it now hey cool man no
problem no problem at all how do you
know about this I don't even know what
that is i'm just a junker man i was just
just check us out you do look like a
junker your way ravage of God just the
outfit man ninja turtle you better stop
poking what is your name my name is
Peter quill okay dude chill out oh why
Ronan may have pushed for you